[Musique]
alors je suis Maya l'aînée la précédente
de la société mamie Lafay qui fabrique
et commercialise des petits pots pour
bébé à base de produits locaux et bio
ici à la Réunion
alors en fait nous on transforme
beaucoup de fruits et de légumes locaux
on a à peu près une vingtaine de
recettes et parmi nos produits stars en
fait on a le petit pot chouchou et en
termes de fruits on a des saveurs qui
fonctionnent très bien comme le banane
fruit de la passion et on a aussi là
qu'on vient de transformer on est en
plein dans la saison le laitchie patate
douce et ça c'est vrai que ça fait
l'unanimité chez les bébés en fait on se
fournit essentiellement auprès des
coopératives bio puisqu'on ne transforme
que des produits certifiés agriculture
biologique de la réunion et on travaille
aussi avec des agriculteurs certifiés
bio en direct
déjà c'est notre première participation
de l'idée c'est d'avoir une visibilité
de pouvoir faire découvrir
aux enfants en métropole et en premier
lieu ça sera beaucoup la diaspora
réunionnaise qui va venir découvrir les
goulots locaux et c'est l'idée aussi de
mettre un premier pied sur le marché
métropolitain
[Musique]